i'm really glad uh to uh introduce the
third speaker of the morning session
uh
katie uh is one of the main organizers
here and i'm really grateful to her for
bringing us all together
and i'm even more grateful for her for
her willingness to give uh
uh this talk today so she'll be talking
about the blob method for degenerate
diffusion and applications of sampling
of two
layer networks
okay thank you very much um for that
introduction and uh you know thank you
to the organizers for um this week's
workshop for inviting me to speak um
so what i'm going to be speaking about
today the work on a blob method for
degenerate diffusion is going to be
based on two works the first with jose
antonio carrillo francesco and francesco
patakini and the second with karthik
ellenbes houthi who's a postdoc at ucla
matt haberland who's a professor at cal
poly and olga ternova who's a professor
at michigan state
so here's my plan for today's talk so
i'm going to begin by giving a little
motivation for the problem that i want
to consider
and basically my goal is to design a new
method for either sampling from a
desired probability density on one hand
or more generally a probability measure
but also uh part of my motivation is to
do this in a way that could also be used
for designing control algorithms for
robotic swarms and in fact my
collaborator karthik allen basuti he
comes from control theory and during his
phd worked on exactly these kinds of you
know fleets of robots
so it turns out that these two problems
can really be put into the same
mathematical framework and my goal is to
design a pd principled algorithm for
either sampling on one hand or robotic
control on the other hand
so the pde that i'm going to propose to
help me solve either of these problems
is a degenerate diffusion equation a
type of weighted porous medium equation
and so while on one hand it shares some
properties with a maybe focker plunk
equation that could be a familiar pde
and sampling to to this audience um in
other ways um it is not as well behaved
um but luckily it shares one key
property with the focker planck equation
which is that it has a two
gradient flow structure with respect to
the two vascular state metric so i'll
talk a little bit about what i mean by
that um and why it's useful in the
context of this problem of designing a
new algorithm for sampling or robot
control
um and the key reason that this vascer
and gradient flow structure is useful
for me in this context is that
phosphorus and gradient flows have a
really nice structure with respect to
numerical particle methods
in other words there's a really nice way
that i can proximate the evolution of
this pde by a system of odes that
describe the motion of dirac masses in
an empirical measure and then under some
assumptions that empirical measure will
converge to a solution of my pde so this
is great this gives me a really natural
way for for
developing a fully discrete algorithm
that could be used in practice
um
and so you know in under nice
assumptions for example if the velocity
field of your bosses gradient flows
globally lipschitz um particle methods
you know naturally pass between the
discrete level of the system of ods and
the continuum level of the pde but
unfortunately for the pde that i'm going
to be focusing on today this degenerate
diffusion equation we lack this kind of
global lipschitz estimate on our
velocity field
so to overcome that and still be able to
develop a particle method for this
problem we have to introduce an
appropriate regularization
and so whenever i have kind of a
particle method that i combine with some
regularization
that's something that i would call a
blob method for diffusive pds and the
reason that i use this terminology is
that it dates back to classical vortex
blob methods for the euler and
navier-stokes equations this is exactly
what they were doing to get around the
singularity of the bios of our kernel
um so i'll tell you what our method is
and i'll explain our main result which
is that indeed this method does converge
to a solution of the pde we have in mind
that allows us to flow towards our
desired distribution and then i'll close
with a few uh numerical examples
okay so let's begin um by motivating the
specific problems i have in mind
um so throughout my talk today i'm going
to assume i have some desired target
distribution robar which
is a probability measure on d
dimensional euclidean space
so if i was thinking about this problem
from a sampling perspective the question
i might ask is how can i choose samples
so i want to choose n vectors in d
dimensional euclidean space so that you
know perhaps at least with high
probability they accurately represent
this desired target distribution
on the other hand if i'm thinking about
this from the control theory perspective
the question i might ask is how can we
program robots to move so that they
distribute their locations
according to robar and a key difference
here is that we want this to be
deterministic so why is that the case
well you know an example of an
application
for this type of control theory problem
is what if you want to broadcast
internet signal to a rural area using
balloons you want the balloons to
distribute themselves in some way in
order to maximize the internet signal
um and so you know we what we would like
is a deterministic algorithm for these
balloons that still works maybe one
balloon goes offline and then the other
ones
adjust their position in order to
continue um
optimizing the signal
and we want this to be a deterministic
algorithm with perhaps even some
convergence guarantees you know would be
the goal
um okay well on the other hand of course
with sampling this is typically
something that's done numerically it's
fine if you run your algorithm several
times in average over the runs to get
the best results
but aside from that kind of key
distinction
that sampling you know can
accommodate some stochasticity whereas
in this control theory algorithm um
perhaps we want something deterministic
um
they're both very similar kind of hit
this uh level which is in both cases we
seek to approximate our desired target
distribution by an empirical measure
so we want to construct a sum of direct
masses either at the locations of these
samples or the locations of the robots
so that as n goes to infinity this
converges to row bar
so in today's talk i'm always going to
be considering equally weighted direct
masses that if you prefer drag masses
with different rates our result goes
through just fine with that as well
um so it's well known that pdes can
inspire new ways of constructing this
empirical measure
and um of course the most classical
connection is between the focker plunk
equation the login dynamics so i think
this is well known to everyone in the
room but i i will recall it just because
it sets up the analogy for the new pde
that i want to consider
so throughout my talk today i'm going to
start um in in the nicest possible case
uh where my target
distribution row bar is log concave and
so i'm going to say it's given by e to
the negative v where v is a convex
function and in fact we'll often assume
or we'll often track this parameter of
lambda and when lambda is positive you
can even get better results than if it's
equal to zero um so you know the
classical um approach using the focker
plunk equation i have up here here i
wrote it in kind of a funny way
when i write the focker plunk equation
in this way it almost looks like a
non-linear equation for rho but if i
expand out the right hand side i get the
familiar focker plunk equation linear
diffusion
with a drift term that depends on my
desired target density
and one of the key properties of the
focker plunk equation you know we
consider this as an initial value
problem so we have some initial location
of our density rho and then we evolve it
in time according to this equation
and
why this is very not useful in sampling
is that if you look at the evolution of
this equation in time and you measure
how different um the solution at time t
is from your desired target distribution
in terms of the cobact labeler
divergence you can show that the cobach
liebler divergence actually dissipates
exponentially quickly in time you know
kind of depending on this parameter
lambda uh
in in your function v depending on how
how strongly conducts your function v is
so in other words this is saying that
solutions in my focker plunk equation
converge very quickly to my desired
target distribution
and you know maybe this is one of the
ideas that underlies um the success of
language defined dynamics is that if
solutions of this pde are flowing very
quickly to the desired target
distribution then if you consider a
discretization of this pde that should
also be going very quickly to the
desired target distribution and that's
exactly um uh what you do you take the
the you know this is a nice linear
diffusion equation so you take a
stochastic particle approximation of it
um and you can show you know in many
senses that this converges um to the pde
but for example you can even show that
if you take the um empirical measure uh
at the locations of these particles as n
goes to infinity this converges to the
solution of your pde at time t almost
surely and so then the hope is that
because you know that if you choose t
long enough your solute solution of your
pde will be very close to desired target
distribution then by choosing t
sufficiently large and then
insufficiently large you can get your
empirical measure as close as you want
to your desired target distribution
okay so this is sort of the uh you know
classical uh approach um and so in
today's talk i'm going to propose taking
a similar approach but with a different
pde
and so here's the pde um that i will
propose at the bottom of the slide you
can see it actually has a lot in common
with that pde up there it's almost as if
i just got rid of the logarithm
and at first you might think that well
you know logarithm is bad it has a
singularity uh it's zero so maybe by
getting rid of the logarithm the pde
gets better but unfortunately that's
that's not true
um
i'm not going to bother expanding out
the whole right hand side because it
gets a little messy but if i expand it
out in the special case that rho bar is
equal to 1 i can see that this becomes a
porous medium equation so it's one half
times the laplacian of rho squared and
the fact that i square row before taking
the laplacian means that solutions of
this pde have much poor regularity
properties than solutions of a
traditional linear diffusion equation
another downside of solutions of this
pde is that we no longer because it's
not a linear diffusion equation we no
longer have this kind of uh rich theory
of stochastic particle approximations
okay so those are some bad things um
but there are still some good things uh
for example you can even show that the
the callback liebler divergence uh
dissipates exponentially quickly along
solutions of this pde
um and so you know uh would it be crazy
to design see if we could design a
particle method for approximating
solutions of this
and then hope that again by taking
insufficiently large and t sufficiently
large we get as close as we want to a
desired target distribution
um so at this point uh it would be very
natural to object and say well katie we
already have this great
linear diffusion equation why are you
why do you want us to now study this
non-linear partial differential equation
and design a new particle method for it
um when we already have this this nice
theory up top
so let me give you a few
items of motivation for why i think um
this pde is worth studying in this
context um
so the first item of motivation um
actually is you know based on the work
of several in this room uh uh work by uh
chewy uh at all uh identified that stein
variational gradient descent can be
thought as kind of a kernelized version
of this type of pde so in a sense you
know maybe understanding the dynamics of
this pde um and and it's you know
discretizations could and uh could in
theory uh help shed light on some of the
properties of stein variational gradient
descent um
another uh reason maybe from a sampling
perspective that you might be interested
in the dynamics of this equation is that
just like you know as some of you may
already be familiar with the focker
planck equation is the gradient flow of
the kovac liebler divergence it
dissipates the colback lever divergence
as quickly as possible with respect to
the vosserstein geometry
this pde dissipates the chi-squared
divergence as quickly as possible with
respect to the oscillation geometry so
perhaps if you had a motivation for
wanting to you know
flow towards your desired target
distribution with respect to chi squared
um this would be the right dynamics to
follow
um there's also some motivation for
studying this pde and it's in its
spatial discretizations coming from
numerical analysis of pdes um so
equations of this type show up in a
variety of contexts across the sciences
for example in models of porous media
and biological swarming
um and so you know by developing a
particle method for this we have a new
numerical method for simulating these
types of processes
a third motivation is that it turns out
the particle method i'm going to propose
for this equation is a deterministic
particle method um not a stochastic
particle method like we had up here for
the focker planck equation
and especially for these types of
applications and control theory uh it
could be useful to have a fully
deterministic method
and lastly it turns out that the
particle method i'm going to propose we
sort of realized after we wrote it down
that it turns out these dynamics
correspond exactly onto the dynamics of
these uh simplified models of training
neural networks training a neural
network with a single hidden layer
in the radial with a radial basis
function activation function and so
part of our analysis is going to look at
what happens when you remove the
regularization and send the particles to
infinity in that
from the optimization perspective is
like
sending the variance of your radial
basis function to zero and looking at
the over parametrized regime where the
number of your neurons goes to infinity
um so we kind of identify the limiting
dynamics in that case
uh and you know then you can kind of say
under what conditions convexity emerges
in the limit which is yeah you know
somewhat uh relevant for these um
simplified models
okay so now i hope you no longer think
it is so crazy to study this kind of cde
yes
yes
so uh yeah i
talk about that a little bit at the end
in terms of uh i think there
i think it's a great direction for
future work to understand i'll i'll say
a little bit at the end exactly what we
need about this robar indeed i'm i'm
going to assume we know the
normalization constant right now but i
think um that would be a very
interesting direction to see
uh
which parts of these things can be
removed in fact
uh yes
it turns yeah anyway let's talk about
let's save that question a little bit
for the end if that's okay great okay
thank you
okay so um
so uh we want to study this degenerate
diffusion equation we want to develop a
particle method for it and we're going
to do that using its vascular sign
gradient flow structure
okay so what is a phosphine gradient
flow i mean this is something that we've
heard about a few times already but let
me just
say it again um basically of osteocyte
gradient flow this is just
a probability measure evolving in time
where
the time derivative of it
coincides with negative the bosses sign
gradient of some energy or in other
words
the probability measure is evolving in a
way
to dissipate a given notion of energy as
quickly as possible with respect to this
phosphor strength structure
so all of the pdes i've mentioned today
are phosphorus and gradient flows
the colback level or divergences of also
or excuse me the focker planck equation
is the vosserstein gradient flow of the
covalent divergence
and this degenerate diffusion equation
that i'll be focusing on today is a
vostorstein gradient flow of the
chi-squared divergence
so in my talk today i'm often just uh
going to make a simplification again you
know relating to leon's question about
the normalization constant because i'm
always assuming that rho bar is a
probability measure i can expand the
square in the chi-square divergence and
write it in this way so it's just
absolute value of rho squared divided by
rho bar plus constant
and this is maybe a familiar way
maybe coming from a background i don't
know relating to problems in statistical
physics i got rid of that robar this is
just a randy and trippy um so this is
you know maybe a familiar way to write
the problem for me
okay um so these are two examples of
oscillating gradient flows or the
gradient flows of these two energies um
of course you know when i take do the
gradient flow of this energy the
constant vanishes so saying it's the
gradient flow of this whole energy is
the same as saying it's the gradient
flow of just that part
um
there are other two other important
examples of pdes that have a vassar
style gradient flow structure um that
will turn out to be important in this
talk
one is called a aggregation equation
with drift
this is a vaser stein gradient flow of
this energy so first we have what's
called an interaction energy and second
we have what's called an external
potential energy
this type of equation arises a lot in
models of biological swarming
um and also gas dynamics uh
and
has been kind of you know studied
extensively over the past 15 years so
i'd say the the theory here is has
become very mature on the the vosser
strength gradient flow side
and i'd like to contrast that with a new
energy that is kind of was identified um
concurrently in several works in the
past few years
which is this energy that arises in
these models of a simplified neural
networks a two-layer neural network
so in this context
you have some data distribution new
you have a target function f naught
and you have an activation function phi
so the variety of phis arise in practice
either a relu or a radial basis function
activation function
and then you have a parameter measure
row
and you want to somehow evolve rho
to
make this energy smaller in other words
to make this parametrization closer to
the target function you know when viewed
on on your data distribution and it was
identified in many of these works that
the training dynamics that people use
with the mean field scaling convention
is exactly like looking at the
wasserstein gradient flow of this energy
um and i mentioned this here just um
okay here i you know i made obviously a
lot of choices here like here i put the
quadratic loss so why did i make that
choice it's just because i made that
choice because when you expand the
square you can see that this energy
suddenly starts to look a lot like these
energies that have showed up
in previous work
so if i expand the square my first term
looks like this if i you know i'm doing
fubini changing the order of integration
and so this turns out to be a kernel
that depends on x and y that i'm
integrating d row x d rho y so very
similar to this though of course it
depends individually on x and y as
opposed to their difference um unless i
pick this kind of radial basis function
activation function
uh and then
similarly here i end up with something
that looks like an external potential
i'm integrated against rho so i
mentioned this because i think you know
i think this is an interesting direction
seeing to what extent the mature theory
here can can shed light on the dynamics
of this kind of energy and i also
mention it because
it turns out that in the case if i
choose
phi to be a radial basis function
activation function i can again
rearrange this term so that it looks
like the integral of phi convolved with
rho squared d new
and so i'd ask you just to keep this
energy in the back of your head because
it turns out it's going to appear again
in a few slides when i tell you how we
design a particle method for this
degenerate diffusion equation
okay so i told you a little bit about
you know what it means that our pde that
we're interested in has a vosserstein
gradient flow structure so how does it
design a
numerical method for a particle method
for it
so a key property about vascular stein
gradient flows is that all vosserstein
gradient flows you know all three of
these equations
um are examples of continuity equations
they can be written in this form that
the time derivative of rho plus the
divergence of rho times some velocity
field equals zero so here i've put the
velocity field in gold
and
just to clarify
my notation it's a little a little odd
of notation so like for example here
my velocity field
okay of course i would have to move
these to the other side of the equation
to write it in this way but here my
velocity field would be
negative grad cake involved with rho
minus grad v okay so
you know and this this velocity field
you know can really depend on on row
um
and indeed you can even formally just
see what the velocity field is um by
taking the first variation of your
energy and the gradient and negative
signs as we're doing gradient descent
okay so vos are saying gradient flows
are solutions into continuity equations
this is not very surprising since they
all describe the evolution of a
probability measure um so how does that
help us design a numerical particle
method um
so here's the the general recipe for
designing a particle method in the
nicest possible case so let's consider
that we have a continuity equation
with a uniformly lipschitz continuous
velocity so here's my continuity
equation and i'm going to put a very
strong assumption on this velocity field
which is that
uniformly in row we have ellipses bound
on it okay so this assumption is going
to be too strong but let us have it for
now because this is where the theory is
nicest
okay so um
in this nice framework
how does a particle method work well
there's three key steps so we want to
simulate a solution of this pde so step
one is we're going to
take the initial data of the pde which
you know in general could be you know a
density of some kind and we want to
approximate it by
an empirical measure
so um you can do this you know in what
in whatever way you like
um
then what we're going to do is we're
going to take the locations in this
empirical measure these xi's
and we're going to evolve them according
to this system of odes
um this maybe doesn't look like a system
of ods the way i wrote it but trust me
it is you know basically what i do is i
take this velocity field and instead of
evaluating it at row where rho is the
solution of this pde i evaluate it at
this empirical measure and basically
what this does is this gives a system of
of in ordinary differential equations
which in general can be coupled so the
movement of the i particle can depend on
the locations of the all the other
particles
so uh it turns out that
solving this system of odes letting the
particles move in this way is exactly
equivalent to saying that the empirical
measure is a weak solution of this
continuity equation in the you know
duality um with smooth compactly
supported functions um and so this is
one of the reasons that particle methods
are so nice when studying uh continuity
equations or vosserstein gradient flows
in particular is that they allow you to
kind of put take the world of odes um
and take the world of pdes and kind of
pass between them and so sometimes
things are easier to do with the od
level sometimes they're easier to do
with pde level and
they allow you to use both of those
tools uh very seamlessly
and so if we have a velocity field that
is really great uniformly lipschitz uh
we're able to show that indeed this
particle method converges to a solution
of the pde in particular what we're able
to say is that if you look at this
empire or the resulting empirical
measure at time t so you let the
particles evolve up to time t
and you compare that in the two vascular
sign distance to the solution of your
pde
you can bound that above by okay
something that deteriorates in time
times the voice or sign distance between
uh your empirical measure approximation
of the initial data and so at least if
you're on bounded time intervals you can
see that by improving this approximation
of your initial data you're able to get
that this empirical measure converges to
a solution of your pde okay and so
that's great so what this tells us is
that when everything is nice
particle methods converge as long as you
make your approximation of the initial
data better and better you're going to
get
that the solution of this particle
method gets arbitrarily close to the
original continuity equation
but of course the question that
is in probably the back of all of your
minds is that what about when v is not
uniformly lipschitz what about when it
fails this incredibly strong assumption
that i put on it um and in fact that is
exactly the case
for these ptes that i'm interested in
for both the the focker equation and the
degenerate diffusion equation this type
of assumption fails um
but interestingly it does still work for
the aggregation equation with drift as
long as these um this interaction kernel
k and this this drift potential v
have bounded hessians
um and so the question arises is there a
way that we can make somehow our
degenerate diffusion equation a little
bit more like these aggregation and
drift equations
uh so that we can get this same nice
property that it's a velocity field has
a global lipschitz bound
and this is where the regularization is
going to come into play
okay so how are we going to regularize
the degenerate diffusion equation to
make it a bit more like these
aggregation equations
um and this is where we define kind of
our regularized particle method or blob
method
okay so at the top i have the degenerate
diffusion equation like we already said
this is the gradient flow of the
chi-square divergence
um and here's the regularization i'm
going to do
i'm going to take the row here
and i'm going to convolve it with a
mollifier phi s1 so you can think of
this as just a gaussian mollifier
now just looking at the level of the
energies
one could hope that under some
reasonable assumptions on rho as epsilon
goes to zero this energy converges to
the top energy so that's uh the
motivation for us you know this is in
some way approximating that energy so if
we look at the gradient flow of this
energy
there's some hope at least formally that
this gradient flow might be
approximating the original gradient flow
okay so
this gradient flow looks really weird
i've got these two convolutions
um it's not totally clear how this is
going to help us so now we have this
really weird partial differential
equation um how is that going to help us
design this sort of method for sampling
and control theory
um
but even though this is a very weird
partial differential equation it has a
really nice property
which is that its velocity which i have
here in gold is global ellipses
unbounded sets
of course that lipschitz constant
deteriorates with x1 so as i remove the
regularization this fails
um oh yeah good question um so i'm i'm
doing the
what i mean by here is this is the
convolution let me add some parentheses
oh oh yes um
uh so so your question is could you have
defined the energy by saying phi epsilon
convolved with
uh
wrote maybe square root of row bar
okay
uh
yeah i think let me see if anything uh
yeah let me let me think if i can see uh
immediately if there was any
reason that we
did or did not uh yeah i think i'd have
to think about it a little bit more if
there was
if there was a reason we didn't consider
that one or not but indeed there are a
lot of choices to be made here and so
this is one regularization we picked but
you know um there's other choices you
could make and and you know
another kind of another direction that's
interesting to look at other types of
exponents here like general exponents
and then when you go there then there's
maybe even more choices that can be made
um but yeah i'd have to think a little
bit if what the kind of
differences then what you really are
evolving is not an empirical
distribution but it's internal entity
estimator right and so
that's the only thing that actually
causes a problem
it actually has a density already
so if you really i mean i'm
yeah i guess it would be like a weighted
curdle density estimator otherwise which
yeah somehow
yeah so
yeah yeah yeah yeah but yeah i think
there is there's clearly a lot of
choices to be made um in some cases i
think we've made the right choices in
other cases like you know we've we've
also have some work on general m um and
i think i think you know maybe we didn't
always make the right choices there and
maybe we can make better choices now so
um
so
yeah i think there's there's definitely
choices to be made
um
yes
can you just say quickly again why
exactly you need um the the the uh lip
[ __ ] the uniform literature yeah and
from a mathematician's perspective you
know i may be being a little bit sloppy
here so so there's a couple of problems
if i try to do a particle method here
first of all what does it even mean to
define that to evaluate the energy of
the sum of direct masses if i try to
flow this energy with initial data
that's the sum of direct masses
instantaneously in time it's not going
to be the sum of drag masses because the
regularizing effect of the force medium
equation so that's one way that you can
say that a problem particle method
doesn't make sense for this equation
um
you know
it's it's a little sloppy of me to say
it's because the velocity field is not
global ellipses because this velocity
field doesn't even really make sense if
rho is you know sum of drag masses
okay
yes
yes yes yes
yeah
okay thank you um okay so because we
have that this velocity field does
satisfy a global ellipse estimate even
though it deteriorates as epsilon goes
to zero we at least know for all fixed
epsilon that this particle method is
well posed and just turning that
particle method crank that i told you on
the previous slide that standard theory
we know that at least or epsilon
positive as n goes to infinity this is
going to converge to a solution of this
weird pde that i had at the top
okay so of course that wasn't our goal
our goal wasn't to come up with a
particle method for this pde it was to
convert come up with a particle method
for the original degenerate diffusion
equation so the key question is what
happens as n goes to infinity and
epsilon goes to zero at the same time
okay so now i
i
have to erase this and make a quick
remark um back to the connection with
these models from two layer neural
networks um which is that you can see
this energy i'm proposing here is
exactly that first term in the energy
arising from uh two layer neural
networks and the key you know row bar
plays the one half is the role of v up
there the data distribution um now two
layer neural networks they have this
additional term depending on an external
potential v
but it turns out that all of our results
are totally fine if you want to add in a
fixed external potential to the energy
um
this i i just left it off for simplicity
of notation um so in that sense um our
identification of the continuum limit
here as n goes to infinity and epsilon
goes to zero likewise sheds light on
this continuum limit these models of
neural networks
okay so here's our main convergence
result i have it at the bottom basically
we do succeed in proving that it
converges to a solution of this pde um
i'm going to say just a few brief words
on the previous work that actually
you may think this is the craziest
particle method you've ever seen in your
life
but it turns out that we weren't the
first to look at this
though all previous work it considered
the case of rho bar identically equal to
one so a uniform target distribution
so
in this you know this work dates back to
olshlogger uh who proved convergence of
this particle method to smooth positive
solutions of the porous medium equation
um on one hand this is you know it's
obviously the foundational work in this
area on the other hand there was clearly
still more to be done because
especially from a mathematical
perspective a lot of our interest in the
porous medium equation is for those
non-smooth solutions especially for
those solutions with the discontinuity
and the derivative at the boundaries
things that are finitely compactly
supported
um subsequently um leona musgalic
uh they proved kind of convergence of
bounded entropy solutions so basically
what they were showing was convergence
of
uh solutions of this pde to this pde as
long as the initial data here had
bounded entropy that doesn't really show
convergence of the particle methods
because the
you know clearly if you're taking the
initial conditions to be an empirical
measure that doesn't have bounded and
trippy
um but it was again you know like an
important step forward
again we did the similar thing again
just convergence of uh
bounded entropy solutions so the initial
date had to bounded entropy um but we
looked for more general um
types of diffusion and you know also
adding in any sort of aggregation drift
term that's fine that doesn't that
doesn't break the analysis
um only for m greater than or equal to
two i
it would be wonderful to do it for m
equals one
um
and then uh most recently in the context
of these models of two-layer neural
networks uh java mandalay and montana uh
proved kind of very similarly in the
spirit of old fogger uh convergence of
the particle method again to these sort
of smooth strictly positive solutions
and the key um
a key benefit of their work is they
extended olshager's argument to include
these extra terms that arise in the
models of two layer neural networks this
type of external potential term
okay so
our exact result um you know the key
difference here is that we extend this
to general data distributions general
log concave data distributions row bar
we're on a bounded convex domain
um and whenever you have two parameters
in going to infinity and epsilon going
to zero the key question is um how are
those related how are those limits
related um and so we have a sufficient
condition for how those limits are
related that ensures convergence of the
particle method i expect that this is
not necessary i inspect that something
better could be done here
so what we have to say is that
the the
the approximation of your initial data
by this empirical measure
this has to go to zero
really quickly depending on epsilon so
this is e to the negative one over
epsilon to the d plus two so this is
basically like saying n has to grow
really fast with respect to epsilon
like i said um
i think there's i think
that's probably not optimal but because
our result is not quantitative we didn't
worry about it too much so as long as n
is going to infinity really fast with
respect to epsilon we succeed in showing
that our particle method converges uh to
a solution of the continuum pde
unbounded time intervals okay so this
was our goal we have developed a
deterministic particle method for this
degenerate diffusion equation
um
uh just another side remark connecting
this back to these models of two-layer
neural networks
what this this shows the immediate
consequence of our result is that
uh
in
in the limit of the over parametrized
regime where the number of neurons goes
to infinity and the variance of the
radial basis function goes to zero the
limiting dynamics are going to be convex
in the vessel sign sense as long as the
data distribution is log convex and the
data distribution times the target
density is concave so it gives you
conditions under which the the limiting
dynamic convexity emerges in the limit
okay so i think i actually already
discussed this and intended on deleting
that okay so now i'll close briefly with
a few numerical examples so this just
gives you a mental image of what we're
doing
so here are just three toy examples so
in purple here the purple lines show the
target distribution we're trying to
approximate
we take 100 particles
we initialize the particles so here we
have plot the particle trajectories
obviously we didn't plot all 100 we just
plotted like 20. um we initialize them
just uniformly between negative 0.5 and
0.5 and then we evolve them in time so
the time axis is the vertical axis
according to this method
and
in order to visualize to what extent the
particles are indeed
approximating the target distribution up
here we plot a kernel density estimate
you can't really see the time zero
unfortunately i think it's too fair too
faint so the time zero is pretty
uninteresting i'll just draw it on the
time the time zero was just uh
you know we we initialized them
uniformly
uh
between negative point five and positive
point five and then we flow them forward
in time and indeed you see that the
kernel density estimate is is
approximating a desired target
distribution
so here this was a uniform target
distribution so this is kind of a lot of
the previous work and this is a log
concave target distribution so that's
where our theorem holds and this is a
target distribution that's not log
concave so our convergence result is not
does it fails or
we don't know yet how to do it in this
case um but you know at least uh in this
example things seem to work out fine
um a key
uh principle of our approach was that we
wanted to use the vosserstein gradient
flow structure to design our numerical
method
why one of the motivating features of
choosing this pde was that it dissipates
the kl divergence exponentially quickly
in time and we in by we indeed observe
that that's preserved at the level of
our numerical discretization until the
discretization air saturates
but we see this sort of still
exponential decay of the kl divergence
you can look at the rate at which
solutions of our equation converge to
the desired target distribution
uh in one dimension it seems to be about
first order in the number of particles
so many directions for future work
one is general rho bar like not log
concave interestingly our proof for the
n goes to infinity epsilon to zero limit
doesn't really use that much about the
log concavity um what's really hard is
just getting well posedness of the
limiting pde when row bar is not log
concave because you lose the convexity
of the vessels and gradient flow
structure um i think we can do it but
it's going to take a lot of work
um another key thing writing back to
leon's original question is what exactly
is the information on row bar that we're
using here um and so a key thing is that
you can evaluate this integral um which
is a pretty heavy requirement so
thinking about these are gaussians
this is a row bar
um so this is in some sense saying you
need you know point wise information
about robar everywhere in your domain um
and so i i think uh
uh interesting direction would be to see
to what extent
approximate weak
one might hope that instead by
approximating row bar by something else
for example a piecewise constant
approximation of the true
you know maybe you have some true rhobar
you sample it you construct a piece by
constant or kernel density estimated
based on that sampling replace that here
run the method and then see
as you improve the approximation of your
row bar does the method indeed kind of
converge to the right thing so i think
trying to get by with less information
on robar is clearly an important
direction
getting anything quantitative you have
no quantitative
estimates um
this something is
i wish someone could do something like
this i think this would be so cool in
the fluids case they know like these
vortex blob methods for the euler and
navier stokes that by picking better
radial basis functions you can get
faster orders of convergence in
particular by picking a radial basis
function so if you convolve it with any
polynomial of degree less than m it
preserves the polynomial they can get
error estimates that look like this
where m
is the accuracy of your mollifier
so by picking m bigger you can fight
against that cursive dimensionality um i
just think that would be so cool to get
any of course we don't even have
anything quantitative so we're kind of
far from this that
seems like it would be cool and then
lastly this is truly an interacting
particle system the motion of the if
particle depends on the locations of all
the other particles so it has order in
squared computational cost quite quite a
bit higher computational cost um than
for example a lot of dynamics
and so you know
obviously in robot control context you
wouldn't want to add any sort of
stochasticity but um maybe for a
sampling context you would be fine just
evolving kind of some k k of the
particles at any time step um and it
would be interesting if that still
preserves the long time behavior of the
method
okay thank you very much
thank you very much katie uh questions
can i ask a question
uh
sure
go ahead yeah can you hear me well no
yeah we do
so uh i mean so i looked a bit into like
blob version of the two layer no network
training before and
back then what we found is that this bit
like just a smooths out your activation
function uh
i mean so it means that relu you sort of
do the average on activation function
and that's equivalent
to deplop i mean to some stance so
have you guys looked into that or
no i i wasn't aware that there were any
regimes in which the relu activation
function could be equivalent to a radio
basis function activation function
no it's because that you're kind of
modified using a gaussian right when you
do a blob method
uh
yeah i wasn't i yeah know that i would
love to learn more about that yeah sure
we're going to talk later um yeah it
sounds great yeah we even have a
write-up on things like that thanks
thank you
thanks
i i'd like to ask a couple of questions
if that's all right
so the first one is like if i remember
correctly the kl divergence contraction
result that actually holds under just
poincare so do you expect like a
poincare assumption plus maybe some mild
extra assumptions would be enough for
for like the
uh yeah so i i expect that while log
concavity of the desired target
desired target distribution is
sufficient for contraction of the kl i
expect that there are
analogous uh assumptions uh that would
be weaker
yeah
okay and the other thing is like um
would you like to explain briefly like
what's sort of the the relationship
between the
like the blob method you end up with and
uh svgd and like in particular if if
what you did like sheds any any light on
svgt
yeah that's a great question um
uh
i guess a key difference between this
and and you know my limited knowledge of
sp svgd is here we're really looking at
the variance of the modifier going to
zero and my understanding was that in
svgd
your interaction kernel had a fixed
variance
it does have a
fixed variance but like
maybe you would imagine that you would
also want to eventually take the
bandwidth of the
kernel well
then this sort of thing definitely could
result
yeah yeah i guess um so something that's
really
nice for us is that we have this
gradient flow structure
playing with limits of these pdes
if you have a gradient flow structure if
you have some really nice lyapunov
functionals dissipating along their flow
is a lot easier um than
you know pds that may lack that kind of
structure um
but it would still be yeah perhaps still
something could be said
thank you
yeah i have a very short question um how
do you expect
in the desired rate between n and
epsilon
yes so i i'll tell you what i do um
so
here i i use the uh analogy i don't know
if you can see probably you can't if
it's blocking you um so like i said
these types of methods actually have a
long history in mathematical fluid
dynamics and numerical analysis of those
equations and there
basically the key idea is that you want
to take
your mollifier slightly larger than the
average inner particle spacing
so that's what i do here and i get good
results so i anticipate that that kind
of scaling relationship between epsilon
and n
at least under some reasonable
assumptions about the row not you're
approximating um should should be enough
yes indeed and and that's where
um
that's where this dimension dependence
comes in in the the analogous fluid
error estimates
um because as you say the inner particle
spacing depends on the number of
particles and the dimension
adding two random variables uh
corresponds to convol
we know that adding two random variables
corresponds to convolving their
densities right so is there any
relationship between the stochastic
particle method and like the convolution
that you are doing in some space
yeah i'm not
i'm not sure
um
i guess
uh
it's not immediate but maybe in in some
space that there might be an
interpretation for this i don't know
yeah maybe
thank you yeah
all right i also have one question so
what goes wrong with anything if you
just try to regularize the entropy in
this way where you would convolve within
the logarithm right so numerically it's
okay
um in times of trying to prove the
result uh a key component of our proof
is that you know we we can prove some
things as long as
the
the energy you're looking at
is something like this
and it's the it's the convexity or
concavity of that so if you tried to if
you tried to replace this with
this
uh it's the kind of the concavity of
logarithm
also the singularity at zero is bad too
um so
uh you know i guess
from a technical perspective it's when
we try to do the cer50 scheme we try to
get lower semi-continuity of the metric
slopes um
and it just
honestly it's even harder
yeah it's just
we can't do it i don't know how it would
be
so so in this new paper it's also the
realizing this ceratic sandy uh
framework right
yeah so that's why we don't have any
quantitative roots
[Music]
let's uh let's thank katie again
right